[Musica]
se chiediamo in giro a chiunque perché
viaggi perché viaggiare la risposta più
frequente che si dà è per vedere posti
nuovi
quindi per conoscere scoprire delle
realtà visibile concretamente visibili e
quindi delle opere d'arte dei monumenti
dei paesaggi delle città però quello che
vorrei oggi mostrarvi e dimostrargli il
fatto che è possibile
volendo anche viaggiare e scoprire delle
realtà che visibili non sono delle
realtà appunto invisibili che non si
vedono o che non si vedono più e che in
qualche modo possiamo vedere lo faremo
soprattutto grazie a degli artisti nella
maggior parte dei casi grazia degli
artisti molto spesso l'arte ha giocato
col concetto di visibile e invisibile e
molto spesso gli artisti hanno provato a
farci vedere cose che non è più
possibile vedere se è vero che non sto
parlando di personaggi che tracciano un
quadrato per terra e dicono questa è una
scultura invisibile questo è un drago
invisibile in groppa al quale potete
vedere una sirena no dente non sto
parlando di arte facile ora sto parlando
di arte con la a maiuscola siamo nel
luogo natale di un grandissimo artista
un grandissimo pittore geremia re che è
l'orgoglio di leverano e quindi oggi
voglio iniziare parlando proprio di arte
con la maiuscola di un grandissimo
artista che ha giocato tanto
condivisibile
siamo nel mondo del surrealismo sapete
che surrealisti pensavano che la vera
realtà la realtà profonda fosse quella
dell'inconscio non quella che vediamo
per quella che noi vediamo veneri
coordinata in qualche modo sistemata dal
cervello mentre invece i surrealisti
cercavano di andare a fondo la realtà
profonda era quella che si esprimeva
secondo loro tramite i sogni
o tramite comunque delle visioni e
l'artista con cui vorrei aprire questo
questo mio intervento è un grande
visionario che ci ha regalato delle
grandissime visioni pensate che lo
chiamavano il tranquillo sabotatore
perché lui con dei quadri che sembravano
estremamente realistici in realtà ci
instillava dei dubbi dei grandissimi
dubbi sulla realtà sto parlando di rené
magritte e rené magritte nel quadro che
vorrei farvi vedere in questo qui si
chiama la firma in bianco qui lui
proprio giocava col visibile e
l'invisibile vedete c'è una cavallerizza
che attraversa un bosco se osservate
attentamente vedete che non può essere
un quadro realistico lo stesso madrid
diceva che in realtà quando un cavallo
attraverso un bosco un pò c'è un po non
c'è ma noi sappiamo che c'è in realtà la
cavallerizza un po copre gli alberi è un
po è coperta dagli alberi quindi questo
è il modo in cui lui giocava con questo
concetto il concetto appunto di visibile
e invisibile però delle volte è la
storia che ci porta invece a
confrontarci con l'invisibilità ancora
oggi sono e viaggiamo in un posto molto
molto lontano
noi andiamo in giappone abbiamo la
possibilità di vedere proprio questo di
vedere un passato invisibile che è
rimasto in maniera indelebile
facciamo un grande viaggio nel tempo
torniamo indietro andiamo a hiroshima
questa è un'immagine di hiroshima una
fotografia scattata i primi mesi del
come vedete una via molto trafficata
negozi luci qui ancora un'altra via
la classica architettura giapponese la
vita quotidiana che va avanti
tranquillamente come ben saprete
all'inizio del 45 nei primi mesi del 45
la guerra finalmente sta finendo la
germania se già arresa hitler suicidato
nel suo bunker di berlino l'italia s'è
arresa mussolini è stato fucilato
ma resta ancora il giappone siamo
all'inizio di agosto e il giappone
ancora non si è arreso anche per
un'etica tipicamente giapponese il
giappone non si arrende il giapponese
non si arrende fino in fondo
e allora come ben saprete gli stati
uniti decidono di ricorrere alle maniere
forti
decisamente quindi una città placida e
tranquilla che sa che c'è la guerra ma
in realtà la guerra si sta svolgendo più
nel pacifico che nel giappone vero e
proprio sulla città di hiroshima come
ben sapete viene sganciata e 6 agosto la
prima bomba atomica della storia
fra i morti che muoiono all'istante e i
morti che muoiono per le conseguenze
dell'atomica si contano 174.000 forse
180 mila morti
solo per questa esplosione tre giorni
dopo a nagasaki si presenta esattamente
la stessa situazione
nagasaki era così questa era una foto
della baia di nagasaki
qualche mese prima che venisse sganciata
la bomba una città ridente la baia di
nagasaki è bellissima ed è anche delle
degli edifici vedete qui la chiesa anche
degli edifici europei perché la casa che
era l'unico porto che durante il periodo
di isolamento giapponese poteva
accettare le navi europee e oggi alla
nagasaki oggi c'è il qui c'è un grande
ponte per entrare nella baia di una casa
che vedete una città bellissima e non a
splendida baia
anche lì la vita quotidiana sta andando
avanti tranquillamente il 9 agosto del
45 un'esplosione nucleare
anche qui uccide meno persona ma si
parla sempre comunque di 80.000 persone
tra personale vengono bruciate
all'istante le persone che poi muoiono
per le conseguenze di questa esplosione
la baia di nagasaki viene ridotta in
cenere vedete rimane la chiesa che vi ho
mostrato prima rimane in piedi alcune
alcuni sono i muri della della chiesa
rimangono in piedi il resto è tutto
morte e distruzione e desolazione cosa
succede
l'esplosione atomica durante la quale si
calcola che nel l'epicentro si sono
raggiunti pensate 7 mila gradi causa
quella che viene chiamata l'ombra
nucleare
guardate bene questo questo edificio
severo osservate questo edificio vedete
che qui è rimasto miracolosamente in
piedi dopo l'esplosione ma qui sono
rimaste delle strisce come se queste
sbarre delle finestre avessero appunto
ha fatto un po da barriera e quindi
avessero consentito la creazione di
queste ombre nucleari
ecco le ombre nucleari si verificano un
po ovunque sia rossi ma che a nagasaki
prete a qui ce n'è un'altra il metallo
ha fatto in qualche modo da scudo
probabilmente perché lontano non proprio
nell epicentro quindi ha resistito però
comunque si è creata quest'ombra
nucleare l'invisibile del nucleare a
hiroshima e nagasaki
quello che vorrei mostrarvi oggi e in
questa fotografia questa fotografia è
agghiacciante
adesso vi spiego subito perché ve lo
spiego dal nome di questo posto se voi
guardate qui a sinistra questi sono dei
caratteri giapponesi si legge così i
tokaghe no kishi il cibo lire pietra la
penetra e questa no è con un genitivo
sassone con la s inglese quindi questo
sarebbe un complemento di specificazione
della pietra questo vuol dire ombra gag
e e questo carattere che ha un po la
forma di un essere umano è proprio il
carattere che indica l'essere umano tito
quindi i tocca gheno e si vuol dire
l'ombra scusate la pietra dell'ombra
umana quest'ombra qui che vedete
e l'ombra di una signora che era seduta
sui gradini di questa banca non sarà
subito amo bank di hiroshima
erano le 8 un quarto quando è esplosa la
bomba quando la bomba esplosa per una
frazione di secondo il corpo di questa
donna ha fatto ha creato una sorta di
barriera e poi si è completamente
carbonizzato ma è rimasta l'ombra
eccola qui oggi questi gradini sono
stati portati nel museo della pace di
hiroshima 1 siano dove bisogna
assolutamente andare per capire quali
sono gli orrori della guerra ma
soprattutto gli errori e gli orrori e
gli errori della guerra nucleare quindi
anche qui vediamo un invisibile
l'invisibile di una donna che c'era e
qualche secondo dopo l'esplosione
nucleare non c'era più ma è rimasta è
rimasta appunto su questa pietra
questa è un'altra immagine di un'altra
ombra nucleare anche in questo caso si
vede un essere umano è una scala sono
spariti sono disintegrati polverizzati
carbonizzati
ma le loro ombre sono rimaste quindi in
questo caso è stato il fuoco a creare a
farci vedere l'invisibile c'è un artista
italiano contemporaneo che si chiama
claudio parmigiani che ha usato
esattamente la stessa tecnica con il
fuoco la polvere e il fumo lui crea la
celebrazione dell'assenza ci fa vedere
l'invisibile
guardate qui si vede una libreria si
vedono dei libri ma in realtà sono stati
realizzati non ci sono lui realizza
queste opere che lui chiama la
delocazioni proprio gettando della
polvere o della cenere o del fuoco e
crea l'assenza ci fa vedere l'assenza
anche in questo caso ci fa vedere
l'invisibile
questa è una foto scattata nel maxxi a
roma e il museo dell'arte del xxi secolo
ma in tantissime occasioni claudio
parmigiani ha creato queste delocazioni
che sono proprio la celebrazione
dell'assenza
e del silenzio è veramente quando voi
entrate in una stanza con una di queste
delocazioni veramente mi viene spontaneo
tacere per una questione di rispetto
vi viene veramente spontaneo tacere e
osservare qualcosa che non c'è
e se parliamo di libri che ci sono e non
ci sono non possiamo evitare di andare a
berlino bebelplatz questa è la piazza si
trova nel partito di mittel quartiere
storico di berlino in questa è la piazza
dedicata alla cultura
guardate qui a sinistra questo edificio
è il teatro dell'opera la cattedrale di
sant eligio questa è una delle sedi
dell'università un bot
e da questa parte proprio dove noi siamo
in questo momento c'è l'edificio ancora
più grande e dell'università un bot
l'università humboldt ha regalato
all'umanità 57 premi nobel pensate che
hegel marx i fratelli grimm max weber e
tanti altri hanno studiato
all'università di un botto quindi alla
piazza della cultura e del posto dove
nel maggio del 1933 è avvenuto del rogo
nazista dei libri il ministro della
propaganda josef goebbels fece un
discorso tende un discorso per infuocare
gli animi dei giovani studenti nazisti
dopo di che gli studenti nazisti
entrarono nell'università presero 20
mila libri e 20 mila libri vennero
bruciati
al centro di questa piazza la piazza si
chiama bebelplatz vedete qui a sinistra
al centro di babel plus oggi per
ricordarci questi libri che non ci sono
più ma ci sono in realtà c'è un
monumento che trovo molto toccante dove
anche lì viene spontaneo tacere per
rispetto
guardate per terra ci si cammina sopra
c'è una lastra di vetro e questa lastra
di vetro nasconde una stanza sotterranea
con degli scaffali vuoti illuminati ma
vuoti quindi sono in pratica dei
fantasmi di libri gli spiriti dei libri
dei 20 mila libri che sono stati
immolati sono lì su questi scaffali
ancora oggi è ancora più forte più
toccante questo di notte perché la notte
sono illuminati quindi nel buio
io della della piazza brillano questi
scaffali vuoti
c'è un'altra un altro grande artista che
ci ha regalato la possibilità di vedere
con l'arte qualcosa che è ormai
invisibile e siamo qui in puglia a nord
della puglia vicino a manfredonia
c'è un posto che si chiama parco
archeologico di siponto a siponto fino a
pochi anni fa la situazione vista
dall'alto da questa a destra si vede una
basilica romanica del xii secolo e qui a
sinistra c'erano i resti di una basilica
molto molto più vecchia molto più antica
del sesso secolo la basilica
paleocristiana c'erano soltanto dei
resti un po di fondamento ha nient'altro
nel 2016 qui è rinata la basilica
paleocristiana grazie a un giovane
grandissimo artista che si chiama
l'edoardo iii soldi la basilica
paleocristiana e totalmente rinata
eccola qui vedete a sinistra se non può
un ologramma ma è reale si tocca
ci si può entrare di cosa è fatta è
fatta di rete metallica la rete
metallica praticamente ricostruito
esattamente come era esattamente nelle
stesse dimensioni
la cattedrale scusate la basilica
paleocristiana e quindi oggi è possibile
entrarci e immaginarla non è come se
l'avessero ricostruita se l'avessero l'è
costruita in pietra sarebbe stata
semplicemente una ricostruzione questa
in rete metallica invece ci dà proprio
l'idea dello spirito della chiesa
all'anima della chiesa non è un caso che
le visite al parco archeologico di
siponto siano aumentate in maniera
stratosferica rispetto a prima
perché prima per comprendere la basilica
paleocristiana bisognava studiare prima
prepararsi saperlo avere un minimo di
preparazione in storia la storia
dell'arte oppure una volta arrivati lì
leggere approfonditamente i pannelli
cosa che non tutti facciamo
e invece adesso chiunque anche la
persona che non sa niente di storia di
storia dell'arte può entrare e vivere
proprio lo spirito di questa chiesa
all'interno ripeto non è come vederla
rifatta in pietra
così con questa rete metallica c'è e non
c'è veramente come fosse lo spirito
della della basilica che c'era prima
questa è l'immagine la sera la sera ha
ancora preso gestiva ancora più toccante
nel pochissimo tempo che mi rimane
vorrei portarvi in sicilia per un ultimo
viaggio in un posto dove l'arte ci ha
restituito qualcosa che non è più
visibile
torniamo nuovamente indietro nel tempo
1968 nella notte fra il 14 e il 15
gennaio un terremoto rade al suolo la
cittadina di gibellina oggi budina come
ricevono in dialetto stanno provincia di
trapani completamente rasa al suolo al
suolo da questo terremoto
guardate queste sono le macerie che sono
rimaste di gibellina le tremendo vedere
questo pianoforte pianoforte attorno al
quale possiamo immaginare una famiglia
che suona che canta dalla gente che
festeggia che fa musica
così tra le macerie di questa città
completamente distrutta
gibellina e stata ricostruita a 20
chilometri dal punto in cui si trovava
prima in un punto anche un po più comodo
per le comunicazioni le macerie sono
rimaste lì un sindaco illuminato si
chiamava ludovico corrao ha invitato
tanti artisti contemporanei a arricchire
la nuova gibellina ma ha evitato anche
un artista che si chiamava alberto burri
alberto burri era stato prigioniero
durante la guerra in texas nella stato
catturato e portato in texas è rimasto
18 mesi prigioniera quindi aveva una
dimestichezza con la terra secca la
terra riarsa la terra argillosa con le
spaccature e creava delle opere di
giocava molto con la materia creava
questo tipo di opera questo lui lo
chiamava il cretto questa è una piccola
dimensione
nel momento in cui
arriva a gibellina vede la città nuova e
non è ispirato ma quando il sindaco
ludovico corrao lo voglio ripetere
perché un grande nome
quando ludovico corrao lo porta nella
vecchia gibellina alberto burri a una
grande idea all'idea di far rivivere in
qualche modo concreto la vecchia
gibellina le macerie erano lì
abbandonate non si sapeva cosa farne le
ha completamente ricoperte di
calcestruzzo e ha creato quello che oggi
ancora oggi si chiama il cretto di burri
questa guardate il pendio della collina
era lì che sorgeva gibellina le linee e
le vie che vedete al centro non
corrispondono esattamente a gibellina
corrispondono più che altro a un'idea di
creto che si era fatta
alberto burri e questo è il posto dove
oggi è una fondazione che siamo alla
fondazione orestiadi organizza anche
delle rappresentazioni teatrali
organizza anche degli eventi quindi non
è un sacrario non è un cimitero anzi è
un posto vivo dove è possibile andare
camminare tra le vie percorrere
idealmente questo labirinto labirinto
del cretto di burri quindi idealmente
ritrovarsi nuovamente nella vecchia
gibellina
questa è stata l'idea di alberto burri
criticata controversa ognuno può
naturalmente vederla come vuole però non
possiamo negare che sembri molto più
viva
adesso di quando quel pendio della
collina era completamente pieno di
macerie
si chiama il cretto di burri si trova in
sicilia e dell'ennesima dimostrazione di
quello che ci diceva il grande pittore
tedesco paul klee che affermò l'arte non
riproduce ciò che è visibile ma rende
visibile ciò che non sempre lo è grazie
mille
[Applauso]